Oh wait, wrong one.
Sorry!
Sorry, wrong screen.
Hello everybody!
Welcome!
I hope you guys had a nice rest day yesterday.
I sure did.
I slept so much.
Oh my gosh, I slept a lot.
Tomatoes!
Oh my god, look at all of you guys.
I can't believe it's been one month of memberships already.
That's actually crazy.
That's a really... I've been like streaming for a month now.
Oh my god.
Congratulations!
I have no other badges other than tomatoes, so...
And we won't be having other badges yet.
Okay?
The reason why is that...
I'm trying to like finalize some stuff right now regarding like my new skin suit.
So like that is why we don't have a badge after the tomato.
Because I'm trying to like figure out what I want to do.
What I want to do for my badges at the moment.
Most likely it will be dragoon themed as always.
But then like I'm like trying to figure out for...
Like after... because like you know after the dragoon badges like what's after that?
I don't know what's after that.
So that's why...
That's why there's no badges other than the tomato badge for now.
We're trying to do everything.
There's so many things I have to do.
Anyway!
I love how like this game has like a rage quit option too.
That makes sense.
That makes sense for the type of game that we're playing today.
For those who are wondering, wow Doki, what game are you playing today?
It's called A Difficult Game About Clash of Clans.
It's a game that's like a rock climbing.
It's not by the creators of getting over it.
It is like a spiritual successor to getting over it by some different person.
Instead of you know a pot and a sledgehammer, we're gonna be rock climbing.
And like okay, I usually never touch these types of games.
But I also had a perfectly good excuse to not touch these types of games.
One of them was that like I could be like...
Ooh, I don't know guys.
Permissu.
But now, I don't really have that anymore.
So like now, I get to feel the FOMO.
The fear of missing out.
You know, because like it just came out and everybody is playing it now.
All the streamers are playing it.
So like no!
Now I have FOMO!
I can't use the excuse anymore!
Because then I could be like...
Well guys, the game came out a long time ago.
And like I don't want to put myself through that.
I don't want to put myself through that.
Because I know it's a really... it's a rage game.
It's a game that's making you supposed to be raging.
The game just came out.
This game... this game just came out.
So now I don't have any excuse.
Because it's the streamer game now.
And now I'm feeling the FOMO.
I'm feeling it guys.
I'm feeling the fear of missing out.
I don't have any excuses anymore.
I'm weak to FOMO.
I...
It's the meta stream game.
I need to follow the meta.
I'm always following the meta.
No!
I'm really feeling the FOMO at the moment.
I'm feeling it.
Okay, also like we're going to have some background music.
Because like this game is like...
It's like water.
You hear...
You hear water.
So let me just...
Let me put like a BGM.
Just to be a little sane.
Ba-ba-bum.
Ba-dum-ba-dum.
I don't know if you guys can hear that.
That might be a bit too quiet.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, so...
The goal...
Is to climb.
Okay, I don't know the game is too loud.
Let me check.
Alright.
Okay, and then we do this.
And then...
How do I...
And then I grab like...
Oh!
Wait!
This is so easy!
What the fuck?
What's so difficult about climbing?
I don't understand.
What can be so difficult about this?
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Wait, I can feel...
Wait, now...
Wait, sorry.
I think I know now.
I think...
Okay, wait.
Wait, I think...
No!
I don't!
Wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait.
I think...
I think I understand now.
I think I understand what could be so difficult about...
A difficult game about climbing.
What?
What's your weak ass hand doing?
Is it...
Oh!
It's cause this water is...
This is a shaky rock.
Cause it's like water...
Oh!
Guys, I'm learning.
I'm learning.
It's a shaky rock.
Okay, now this is the easiest fucking game I've ever played.
Ba-ba-dum!
Okay.
Can I grab...
Can I grab can?
I can.
Okay.
I mean, the controls are very intuitive.
Like, it's not...
I swear to God.
Can I grab the side?
Yeah, okay.
Alright.
It's not...
You know, it's not that stupid.
Okay, I need to remember what you...
What?
No!
I can just swim away.
I can't believe it.
Okay, now I know.
Now I can feel it.
No!
Guys, now I understand.
I understand now.
I don't understand!
Why couldn't you climb?
Okay.
Alright.
At least, like, I died there.
You know?
It's not that bad.
Boom.
All right.
Here we go.
Up and then... climb?
There we go.
I got this down.
I mean, this is...
Honestly, the controls for this?
It's...
I'll say it.
It's easier than getting over it.
It is 100% easier than getting over it.
It's, like, so intuitive.
Like...
Even a fucking child can do this.
Now I need to figure out how to get over there.
Okay, come on.
Use your upper body strength.
Come on!
Yes!
Your arm can go further!
Yes, okay.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
He stretched himself.
Alright, and then we're gonna climb this fucking bark.
Okay.
That's good.
Alright, where the fuck do I go from there?
I don't know.
Okay, we're gonna grab...
We're gonna...
Please.
Okay, this...
I hate this BGM.
I might have chose, like, the fucking worst BGM ever.
Okay.
Please.
There we go.
We're fine.
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
Where do I go?
Okay.
Oh no.
No, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
I don't understand!
Why can't he use his legs?
Is he stupid?
Like...
I don't understand!
Why do I lose my grip there and not the other way around?
I need... the sense needs to be higher.
I can't.
Is he fucking stupid?
Why can't he fucking grip that?
Okay.
Alright.
I can speedrun this part.
Okay.
No!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Alright.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Please.
Please!
Just grip it!
I don't understand why you're weak to water!
Okay.
It's okay.
We're good.
We can speedrun this part.
Like, this part is easy.
Oh!
Don't go too fast!
Okay.
Nice.
I'm speedrunning this part.
Okay.
Yes!
Alright.
We're good.
Okay.
What do we do here, though?
I don't know.
Do I... Do I...
Okay.
I gripped that.
And I gripped the box.
Okay.
Come on.
Yes!
Go higher.
Higher than you've ever gone before, Mr. Man.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh!
I'm up!
You know, this game is pretty easy, actually.
Okay.
If I just keep...
Oh, I can grip bushes!
Wait, that's new information!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Just keep gripping the bushes.
Yes.
And up I go!
Yes!
Up you go, sir!
Nice!
Wait, what?
What do I do?
Wait.
What do I do from here?
Down?
What?
I don't want to go down!
I worked so hard to get here!
Wait, what?
No!
Don't make me go down!
The leap of faith.
Okay.
Here we go.
No!
Why did I listen?
Why did I listen to you guys?
Okay.
So, is the BGM too loud or is it good?
No!
Why did I go down?
It was too much pain.
Too...
Not...
Doki, not that down.
The other down.
Oh, shit.
It's too quiet?
Okay.
I didn't realize it was too quiet.
I've been listening to the sound...
This BGM, like, blasted up to my ears.
Did you guys hear that?
Okay.
I'll turn it up a little.
Over now.
Alright.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Like, I'm starting getting better at this.
No!
It's not that difficult.
I would say this is easier than getting over it.
100%.
See, look at me.
I can, like, speedrun this.
Let me...
Maybe I should watch a speedrun.
Shout out to the highest working link cop ever.
Pass the point.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
If I, like, do this and then...
Yes.
Okay.
You just keep climbing.
You won't let this...
Okay.
Nice.
Push.
Good job, push.
Okay.
Come on.
You got this.
Come on, sir.
No!
Don't let water destroy you!
It's just water!
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
Keep climbing!
Just keep climbing!
Scratch and break your nails!
Okay.
Alright.
We're fine.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
And then...
Okay.
No.
We're gonna use that to boost our momentum and go...
Wait.
What the fuck?
How did you lose your grip?
There you go.
Nice.
I figured it out.
I figured out the system.
And then we grab this.
Oh, God.
This is scary.
No!
No, no, no, no!
Ahhh!
Why?
I'm in a game of controller.
Okay.
Up.
Higher.
The sensitivity must be higher!
Okay.
Honestly, I think it's like, you max out the senses, the way to go, honestly, at this point.
Wait.
Alright.
Okay.
Nice.
We got this one down.
Alright.
And then... I don't understand why my grip will sometimes get fucked.
I don't understand.
Okay.
Alright.
And then we just keep... Boost!
And then we grab this.
And then... Okay.
Okay.
Boost!
Nice.
Okay.
Here we go.
This is the way.
Boost!
Sir!
Pull up!
Okay.
Here we try again.
Pull up!
There you go.
I'm like... Honestly...
There might be a time where I pull out the controller.
I feel like...
A controller might be easier to handle.
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay.
I want to grab the other hand.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
I didn't grab the tree branch there.
Alright.
Here we go.
Bush!
Okay.
No.
That's not a bush.
Okay.
We need to grab...
We need to grab the grass.
Grab the grass, sir.
Okay.
Here we go.
And we need to grab a higher upper of the grass.
Okay.
One.
Two.
Three!
Yes!
Good job!
Alright.
This part...
I don't know.
Do I just swing?
What?
Okay.
I swing.
That was scary.
That was a little scary.
Okay.
I'm gonna use bones now, too.
Alright.
What do I do here?
Do I...
Do I swing?
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this!
Do I...
No!
That's a bad idea!
I don't...
I'm so scared!
Bone!
Okay.
Do I go down?
Do I...
No?
Go up?
Where?
Where go?
Where do I climb?
Okay.
Poe not good?
It's true!
I hate FOMO.
Backseaters!
This is your time to shine!
No!
Do I swing?
Damn you FOMO!
But the bone zone...
Why are Rage Games streamer games?
God damn it.
I wish I was a game programmer so I can make Rage Games.
Hey guys!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Nice demonstration.
I can see your skill and how you got this game figured out.
Exexpect... Yeah.
Yeah.
I... I figured it out.
Yeah!
Figured it out.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh yeah.
I forgot how's the sound by the way.
I forgot to ask you guys how you think about the sound.
If it's too loud or if it's perfect.
Alright.
At least I got this part down.
Like this part is fucking easy.
This part is for fucking babies.
Which is soft.
The game sound or... Okay.
Do you really need to know about like... Do you really need to know the game sound of this man?
All he's doing... Oh my god.
All he's doing is just grunting.
Like in the water.
Like that's all he's doing.
He's just grunting.
So you guys don't... You're not missing out.
You're not missing out right now.
Don't worry.
There's no FOMO to be had here.
Okay.
Here we go.
The grunting is important.
Don't understand Doki.
We need to hear this man go...
It's important!
Okay.
Here we go.
There.
I'll voice act it for you guys.
It might just be the same.
Here.
Please.
Please grab onto this.
Okay.
Come on.
Boost yourself up.
Boost yourself up!
Come on!
Boost!
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
We got the boost.
Okay.
We need to pick this up.
And then...
Okay.
One!
Two!
Three!
There we go.
Nice.
And then... Yes!
Okay.
I need to grab... I need to grab this side.
No.
It's not what I want.
Okay.
One.
Two.
Three.
Nice.
We got it.
Okay.
We got this down.
This part is super easy.
This part is like really easy for me.
The scariest part is the dropping down because like I don't have faith in anything.
Okay.
One.
Two.
Three!
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
We gotta fall now.
I don't wanna fall.
I don't...
One.
Two.
Three!
Okay.
Don't worry.
What is... I hate this stuff.
Okay.
Here we go.
Where do I go from here?
I don't understand.
Where do I...
Do I swing?
There's no way.
There's no way I can make it.
Do I make it?
No!
Full swing?
Okay.
One.
I'm scared.
Guys.
I am so scared.
The sign?
What sign?
Okay.
Full swing?
What if we don't make it?
Higher up?
Here?
We go?
Higher?
But like... That's where I came from!
What do you mean?
Aim for the side.
But how?
Okay.
Go high.
And then...
Okay.
No.
You're too far.
Guys.
I'm scared.
Okay.
One.
Oh god.
This is where it gets difficult.
We're already down?
Okay.
One.
Two!
No!
What?
Grab the bone.
Swing for the side.
Okay.
I just need to grab the bone.
Alright.
Grab the bone.
Okay.
What's the world record currently?
What even is the current world record?
For this game?
Like...
Well...
Okay.
SEVEN FUCKING MINUTES?!
BRO!
What are you doing?!
What are you doing, Doki?!
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Well, at least I'm like, feeling this game now.
I'm feeling it.
I'm feeling this game now.
I don't even need to do the boost.
I can just like... I can just do regular bounces.
Now I need to do the boost though.
Here we go.
Up.
Up I go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, Doki.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
I need to do this arm.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
One.
Two.
Three.
Don't fall, don't fall, don't fall.
Okay.
Don't fall.
Okay, we got this part down.
We just need to start.
We just need to...
Where's your other... no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Where's your other car?
I'm going.
Where is it going?
All right, nice.
No!
Why did the bush fail me?
Why is the bush failing me?
I fucking hate the water!
Okay, I'm good.
I'm okay.
I need to turn down the BGM.
The BGM is pissing me off.
Why are you so stupid?
Use your fucking legs!
I don't understand.
Okay.
It's only been 26 minutes.
I swear I feel like I've been playing this game for an hour already.
I hate FOMO.
Okay, here we go.
I swear, it feels like I've been playing for like...
hours.
I feel like I've just like witnessed everything in life.
Okay, let's see.
All right, nice.
We grab that and then we grab this.
And then...
Okay.
I can't...
Swing!
There we go.
All right.
Swing!
There we go.
All right.
Swing!
You're gonna hit it.
Yeah.
Here we go.
One...
Two...
Three.
Okay.
All right.
One, two, three!
Nice.
We grab that.
Like this part is like super easy now.
But like...
Oh my god.
As I get higher and higher...
Holy shit!
By the way, guys.
I was like talking to the Minecraft team.
The people who are...
For those who are gonna be members, if you guys don't know.
We're gonna be creating a members of Minecraft community.
Community server.
I was talking to like the Minecraft team.
And we're like talking about like faction...
Making factions and stuff.
So like basically...
Okay.
Wait.
Give me a sec, guys.
Sorry.
You're gonna be on a cliffhanger because I need to get to the other fucking side.
Give me a sec.
Swing!
Okay.
Anyway.
As I was saying...
So thank you for the machete.
Super.
Thank you.
Doki is a pro climber.
Expected.
Thank you.
All right.
So like the most exciting part is that we're talking about how to do the faction stuff.
And like basically like...
Oh.
Okay.
Sorry.
I had to...
Okay.
Basically, it's gonna be when you enter the town.
When you enter the lobby, the pre-made town.
You get to pick your faction.
So like obviously the faction is gonna be divided by like long goon, chunky goon, egg goon, and like regular goon.
And like...
And then like...
There's gonna be like power levels.
And like the stronger your faction is, the more land you can claim.
So technically you could be like...
You can like wage wars against other dragoons.
For more land.
And like...
And like there's gonna be like a communal bank system or something.
And...
So like the more...
The more dragoon types you kill...
Like the more enemy dragoons you kill, the more land you can claim.
Like like...
So...
I was like talking to like the Minecraft team about that.
Alright.
Here we go.
Let's see.
I need to figure out how to swing.
Which is the best area to swing from?
Like do I go higher?
Or...
Haha.
I don't get it.
Do I go higher?
Do I swing from the bone?
I thought I can't touch the bone.
Bone!
Okay.
The bone is... yeah, the bone is slippery!
What do you mean?
Okay.
Bone bad!
Everything changed with the Nes-tical faction attack.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, closer to a sign.
Let me know.
Do hot and cold.
Am I hot?
Sorry.
Am I close to the thing?
Am I cold or hot to the area?
Okay.
A bit higher area.
A bit higher here?
Is that it?
Am I at the swing?
The optimal swing?
Guys, okay.
I need to know this is important, guys.
Am I at the optimal swing?
A bit higher?
Here?
Oh, God.
No!
Where?
Too high?
Okay, here.
Here.
Is this it?
Is this the optimal swing?
Cold!
Cold or hot?
I'm not gonna wing it!
Lower?
Okay.
Okay, here.
Is this optimal swing?
I swear to God.
I will pull up the fucking speedrun of this just to figure out which is the optimal swing.
Okay.
What?
No!
I'm fucking pulling up the vine.
Give me a sec.
Difficult game about climbing speedrun.
I'm pulling up.
I'm fucking...
Alright, 7.55.
What the fuck?
It goes to a... Why is it purple?
Okay.
What the fuck?
Guys!
Okay.
I blame you guys.
This could have been so much easier.
Guys, I can't believe you made this harder than I expected.
I can't believe it.
Alright.
I should have just...
I should have just fucking watched a professional.
I see.
Yeah, why is he purple now?
Alright, here you go.
I can't believe it, guys.
My Oshii matpack graduated.
Like...
Was it yesterday?
I don't even remember.
Guys, he's my Oshii, but I don't even remember.
I can't believe it!
Biggest graduation stream I've ever seen!
Alright, here you go.
Sad.
I can't believe it.
I like how he made... I watched a little bit because I was curious, like, what his last video was gonna be.
And then, like, I love how, like, he...
He, like, announced a website and it literally crashed in one second.
Like, I thought... I was like, is this a virus?
Because I was like, what is this website?
And then, like, what the fuck?
It literally crashed the moment it was posted.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright, we're good.
We're good.
This is fine.
This part I got hands down.
Oh.
Except for that part.
This part I got, like, easily.
Alright.
Oh, seven to our Oshii MatPat.
Now, who am I gonna go to for all the wacky FNAF theories?
Alright.
It's funny though to see him, like, call out Scott for, like, stealing his theories.
But Scott literally made him.
The creator of FNAF blu...
Like, his... his... like, yeah, his videos were popular.
But, like, FNAF made him for who he is.
Okay.
Let's see.
Here we go.
What the fuck?
Okay.
That is, like, so scary though.
Every time...
Every time doing that leap of faith...
Okay.
It's, like, here.
This is the... the spot.
The optimal swing spot.
And then you go like this.
Okay.
Wait.
And then...
Oh my god.
This is so scary.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I need an ally.
Okay.
He is giving me a sick... How does he do it?
How does this man do it?
Okay, he grabs... Oh my god!
That's so scary!
How does he do that?
Okay, am I at that right spot?
Is it higher?
It's higher.
Okay.
Okay, it's like here.
This is how he does it.
This is so scary.
I have to believe.
What?
What
does it matter if I'm cheating?
I can't even get it right!
Okay, wait, wait, but... I can't even get that shit right!
What does it matter?
But what I did learn... What I did learn... What I did learn!
How does he do it?
Please!
This would save so much time!
Please, purple guy!
No.
Okay, this would save so much time though.
Just think about it.
Please.
This would save so much time.
I know you can do this.
No, you can do it!
I... Fuck it, I give up.
We're fucking... We're not meant to speedrun.
We were never meant to speedrun, guys.
We were not meant to speedrun.
We're just a streamer.
Okay.
Look, I speedrun real games like Peppa Pig.
Not a fucking difficult game about climbing.
And you won't see this in SDGTQD.
Okay.
Please.
No, I'm losing it.
I'm losing my touch.
No, no, no, you're not losing it, Doki.
You gotta believe.
Come on.
Come on, this is so easy for you!
Okay.
No, this is not the right angle.
This is not the right angle.
Okay, one, two, three!
There you go.
I mean, the controls aren't bad!
The controls aren't bad!
It's a fun game!
Oh no, please, please, please, please!
Grab some sand!
Okay.
Come on, up you go.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh god, oh god.
Okay.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
And we have to swing from here.
Okay.
I got the swing for this down.
Yeah, okay.
Like, I got the leap of faith for this down.
But how do you do this?
Like...
What arm is this?
Okay, that's this arm.
Okay.
Can I climb this?
Why can't I climb this?
Give me...
Give me... If I... Give me... Why can't I climb this?
I don't...
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh, oh, oh, please.
Oh, please, climbing guy!
Sir!
Please.
Think of the children.
Here.
Oh no, I don't like this.
I don't like this!
Oh, please.
Oh god, oh god.
I'm so stressed out.
Swing!
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh.
No!
Okay.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
I'm gonna fall.
I can feel it.
I can feel, I can feel the fall.
Oh, please!
Let me touch you!
Oh, she falls.
She falls.
Please!
Ah!
I'm looking up the speedrun.
There is a way to get there faster!
I need a note!
Okay, teach me purple guy.
Teach me purple- what the fuck am I watching?
Okay, okay, purple guy.
Purple guy, teach me!
That's fucking right!
I can do this!
Go purple guy, go!
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Okay, give me a sec.
I still need to figure this out though.
I figured it out guys.
Purple guy taught me.
Watch this.
You guys wanna see something cool?
Okay, not yet.
I caught you!
I caught my time!
So guys, I pioneered that.
I just- I made up that trick today.
Guys, isn't that cool?
Guys, I made up that trick guys.
Oh my god, please.
It's not plagiarized!
It's called the Doki Grasp!
Trinkmarked by Doki.
I discovered it today.
Guys... damn.
I trademarked it.
Guys, call me a- who is it?
Who is the guy who steals all- I mean, who like invents everything?
Thomas Edison.
Wait, no.
Guys, Tesla who?
Okay, here we go.
Okay, wait.
Wait, we got this.
Alright.
He was a genius!
Thomas Edison inventing all these inventions.
That's right, he's my role model right there.
Guys...
Who the fuck is Tesla?
All I know about Tesla is that it's a car.
That's his only contribution to society.
He tried to fucking frame my Oshii Thomas Edison for stealing ideas?
Fucking...
He's the loser who didn't trademark.
Alright, let's see.
Guys...
But I want to grow up.
I want to be just like Mr. Edison.
Inventing all those cool ideas.
Just like- I'm getting there!
I invented the Doki-Doki Crasp!
Oh my god, speed-runners are gonna use- Okay, anytime you see a speedrunner that used my patented Doki Grasp, just remember I did that.
I pioneered the Doki Grasp.
Watch this.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, sorry, wait, wait, wait.
Sorry, okay, so for those who would like to learn speedrunning, what you do is that you put your hand right here.
And then you go down and then you go up.
And then, sorry, this is what you shouldn't do.
This is what you shouldn't do.
So what you should do is like this.
Oh, okay, so what you should do...
is like this.
Okay, guys, give me a sec.
Guys, give me a sec.
Guys, guys, don't worry, I'm trying to... I'm teaching you what the wrong ways are.
Oh, God, please.
Please, there you go.
No!
Please!
The Doki Grasp!
Patented by Doki Bird!
Okay.
Doki Grasp.
Doki, just grasp it.
Doki Grasp!
I don't understand why is this so much harder now.
I don't understand.
I was doing so well.
I was doing so well with the Doki Grasp.
Yeah, sorry.
There's like so many people that have been doing the grasp wrong.
I'm trying to show you all the wrong ways to do it.
Before I do the right way.
Come on.
No, you're strong enough for this.
Come on!
No!
I see how it's safe.
It does!
It saves so much time!
Look at me go!
That's like you're right.
My pure spite and anger.
Fuck you whoever said that.
I did it for you.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I don't know why I did that.
That was way too risky.
Okay.
No!
Please!
Why is it so difficult?
How did I go to grasp that?
I don't understand!
How does he do it?
How?!
How do you do that?
How did you do all of this?
Oh my god.
Okay.
The Doki drop.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't drop.
Every time I fall it's like strategic.
Guys, I just felt like I'm going to drop.
I reset my timer.
Guys, I reset my timer every time I drop.
Because I feel like it's just not...
It's just not an optimal time!
As a fellow speedrunner, you would understand, but you're not.
You don't understand because you're not part of the group.
Look at that!
Fuck!
Okay!
Guys, I just wanted to do it again.
I was like, that was way too easy.
I knew people didn't see it, so I had to do it again.
Guys, I was like, oh my god, that was way too fucking easy how I grasped that.
So I had to do it again for everybody that missed out.
Okay.
Please.
Okay, wait.
There you go.
Alright, there you go.
You guys saw that?
Alright, good.
Because I'm not doing it again.
I felt like I was giving you guys too many examples on how to do it.
And you guys gotta learn eventually.
Okay.
That was a little risky.
That was a little too risky for me.
Okay.
No!
I didn't let go!
It's hard!
Why?
Why is the Doki so...
Guys, I just haven't perfected the Doki.
I just haven't perfected the Doki swing.
I just haven't perfected the Doki swing, guys.
We will see more than just the rock.
There's a town nearby!
Apparently there's a town!
I wanna see the town!
Let me see the town.
Please.
That's all I ask.
I just wanna see the town.
Please.
Please let me see the town.
Let me see the town!
Okay.
Alright.
That's all I want.
That's all Doki wants.
She wants to know what the city looks like.
Okay.
We're almost there, guys!
I will perfect the Doki swing!
Okay.
What the fuck?!
How did I do it?!
I don't understand!
How the fuck did I do it?!
It needs work but the Doki drop is on point.
Thank you for the Hakka soup.
Thank you.
I don't understand!
How did I do it?!
How?!
Okay.
It was just so perfect that I can't perfect it?!
We're good.
There we go.
Okay.
Alright.
We're good.
We're just gonna keep climbing.
Keep climbing.
You will get the Doki swing!
Give me a second.
I need to look at a professional.
Time out!
It's like basketball where you get your coach in.
Guys, don't worry.
I have a coach.
Don't...
Don't worry.
I have a coach.
How the fuck does he do that?
Is it because he has a top hat?
Is it the top hat?
Is it the fucking top hat?
How do I get the top hat?
Okay, I need to make sure I don't fall.
What arm is this?
Oh god, okay.
Okay, here we go.
It must be the hat.
I think it's the hat.
I think it's the fucking hat.
There's...
Oh god!
I need a timeout!
The timeout worked, guys!
The timeout!
Oh god.
Using foot.
Guys!
If I could use a foot, I would use a foot!
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh god, it's okay.
It's okay.
It gives me more chance to perfect all my techniques.
Guys, it's like that... it's like that... that kung fu movie where like you do like meaningless tasks... you think like they're meaningless tasks.
But like all these techniques that we're learning now...
Like the... like the... like the doki... the doki grasp... it's gonna help us in the long run, guys.
Guys, like that shit... look at that.
Look at that.
I figured out the shortcut too.
Okay.
No!
Yeah, yeah, karate kid!
We're just karate kidding it right now!
The doki grasp is gonna save lives!
You don't understand!
We're just slowly perfecting doki grasp!
And then it'll be like baby mode.
I'm just gonna put on...
You'll see.
You'll see, guys.
The moment I let go of my training weights...
You'll see.
Okay, here we go.
Oh!
Please.
Okay, okay, here we go.
Oh god, please, please, please, please.
Please.
Just firmly grasp it.
We perfected you.
What happened?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I told you we perfected it.
I knew we perfected this.
Look at that.
Look at how fast we cut time!
Okay.
Oh!
Oh my god!
The doki swing.
Here it comes.
Oh my god!
We're doing it!
Okay.
Time out.
Basketball time out.
Basketball time out!
What did I do?
How does he do it?
How do you do that swing?
Okay.
He was like...
Basketball time out.
Don't worry.
We're back in.
Benny, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
I can finally watch stream again.
I'm free!
Welcome back, Benny!
Oh god.
Okay.
Grasp.
He grasped this.
Okay.
Coach said...
Guys.
I need to put my hand right here.
And then do...
A swing!
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
And then...
No!
No, no, no.
Coach!
Okay.
And...
And then...
A swing!
Okay.
Coach.
Coach, I need help.
Coach, I need help!
Please.
Coach.
How do you do this?
Okay.
And then...
Oh my god.
Please, please, please don't.
No!
My god.
Why is that part so difficult?
Oh my god!
I just want to see the town!
Let me see the town!
I don't want to finish this game!
I just want to see the city!
That's all...
That's all I want!
I don't even care!
I never want to finish this game!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Each atom of that stone, each mineral, flake of that night-filled mountain, an item forms the world.
The struggle itself towards the height is enough to fill a bird's heart.
One must imagine Doki is happy!
I'm so happy.
Guys!
There's a city!
I saw a city!
The coach saw a city!
It exists!
It's like the fountain of youth!
It exists, guys!
I'll be the Spaniards...
who discovered the city!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, Doki, for showing me how to master the Doki dive!
Now I feel like a true speedrunner!
No!
This won't be my legacy!
Oh my god, the Doki swing!
The Doki swing is getting better and better!
I refuse to let that be my legacy!
Oh god.
Please.
Come on, man!
Come on!
Man, come on!
Just grasp it!
The RC Civilization!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, I just wanna see the city!
Please!
I just wanna know what the city looks like!
They must have fiber over there!
Oh god.
At least, like, that part is getting easier.
Of course it's easy!
I fucking trademarked that!
Of course!
Doki, what are you trying to say?
Of course it'll be easy!
You literally trademarked this!
God damn it, swing!
Too much!
Oh, shit...
Nice and thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Doki, I'll be like the Batgirl banner!
Oh!
I'll go check it out later.
Alright.
Don't worry.
But first...
Doki must grasp.
And Doki must swing.
Don't worry.
Oh my god, please.
Please stop worrying.
Guys, please stop worrying.
Doki's got this.
I'm gonna try to get this.
God, please.
Guys, why are you worried?
Why are you worried, guys?
Doki's got this!
Doki, what happened?
You were a master?
There you go.
Good job.
God, why are you so fucking good at video games?
Okay.
No!
Stop!
Why are you...
I can't believe it.
Please!
Patches, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's really cool that they break up this swimming game with a bit of rock climbing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I swear.
I'm pretty sure more than 50% of the game is me climbing.
You can't say that.
How dare you!
This is the stream where I've discovered the speedrun technique.
Please.
Oh, God, okay.
Alright, we got this down.
How dare you.
This is a master at work right now.
This is literally a master at work.
Oh, God, please.
Please.
Oh, my God.
The Doki Sleeve!
Oh, God, I almost fell off.
I let go.
I was so excited.
I actually let go.
I knew it.
I knew the Doki Sleeve was right!
Okay.
The Doki Sleeve.
The Doki Sleeve will always prevail.
There were so many doubters.
So many people that didn't believe in me.
That's right.
You're all Teslas.
You'll never be like Thomas Edison!
My Oshii!
You'll never be as great as my Oshii.
You're all Teslas!
What a wild statement.
There you go.
How dare you say Edison sucked.
Edison invented everything!
There's the money after this stream.
Okay.
Where do I go from here?
Where the fuck do I go?
I don't want to go in the water.
What if I die?
I don't know if I can...
Is this a checkpoint?
Guys!
This is important.
Is this a checkpoint?
Do I drop?
Yes!
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, I didn't get one guide.
I was worried that I'd get one guide.
I was so fucking worried.
Alright, here you go.
Congratulations, you finally finished the tutorial.
Good luck.
Thank you for the chat.
Thank you.
Oh, God.
I'm scared here actually.
Okay.
Grasp the bush.
Grasp the bush!
Okay, here you go.
I made it.
Guys.
I made it to the first checkpoint!
Wait.
Do I grasp this?
Yeah, I think so.
Okay.
Alright.
This is good.
One minute.
Please.
Okay.
We're not gonna...
We're not gonna go down.
Ugh!
Come on!
What would Edison do?
Always tell yourself!
What would Thomas Edison do?
Your words of motivation is right here!
No!
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, God.
Where's my other hand?
Where is it?
It's not there.
Edison would not fall.
Edison would never...
Edison would never give up and will keep on stealing ideas!
I mean, um...
He is a great inventor, guys.
While I'm climbing in swimming game.
Thank you for the super chat, beast.
Thank you.
Channel Edison.
Here.
This is it.
Alright, here we go.
You would never fall!
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Gotta get a bit closer.
Gotta get a bit closer to that bush.
Before we can...
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Here we go.
Alright.
This is it.
We gotta...
Grasp the bush!
Okay, the bush has been grasped.
Alright.
I am so scared.
Oh, God.
I don't like this level.
I don't like this level at all.
There's too much water.
I hate water.
Why must we need water to survive?
What has water... You know what?
I wish the human body never needed water.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, and then...
Come on.
There's a rock right here!
Okay, nice.
What has water done for me?
Nothing!
Okay, this way.
Why must we need water?
It's stupid!
Oh, God.
That is like such a fucking scary bush right there.
Okay.
This way.
Down we go.
Is that...
Is that bush I can grab?
I can't tell!
I can't tell what I can grab and what I can't grab!
No, that's just rock.
Okay.
Wait, what?
What do I grab?
Down here?
Okay.
Come on.
Your arm can extend higher!
Don't fuck with me!
Okay.
I know your hand can extend higher than this!
That's a scary rock there.
I can't!
I'm trying!
I'm trying to grab!
Okay.
Alright.
AHHHHHHH!
Whoa.
That was close.
That was a little too close.
I didn't like that.
Guys, I might have to call a timeout.
My coach might want me to call a timeout, guys.
I...
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
Up.
Up, Baco.
No!
Sanctuary!
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I might have to call a basketball timeout, guys.
Okay, bye.
No coach, only climb.
Do you think Michael Phelps didn't do it all by himself?
Michael Phelps I don't know if you guys know.
Other than his fucking proportionally abnormal fucking body.
Because his fucking arms are longer than like the fucking rest of his body.
He needed a coach too, guys.
It's not just genetics.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, this is it.
This is it.
Okay, we grassed the bush.
We grassed the branch right here.
Here we go.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
Guys, it's not just genetics.
We have to remember the coaches we have all along!
You think Thomas Edison did this all by himself?
He did.
He's a fucking genius and that's why he's my Oshie.
Don't believe the lies Tesla says.
The only man that never needed a coach was Thomas Edison.
All him.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
That's why he's my Oshie.
Okay.
This is an anti-Tesla sound.
I'm a Tesla anti.
That's looking right.
I will die a Tesla anti.
He didn't steal Jack's shit!
That's what the haters said!
You don't have proof!
It's been hundreds of years!
Move on!
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh my god, please.
Let me.
Let me go around.
No.
Okay.
Thanks!
Okay, grass.
Okay.
No!
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Tesla's landing.
I love pressing it.
Thomas Edison edition.
Edison edition.
Guys.
Move on!
Edison won!
Move on, Tesla fans!
Okay.
This is it.
Ugh.
I don't know what to do.
I don't remember how I did this.
What is this game?
It is a game that reunites...
It's helped to inflame my love for my Oshie.
Tesla shitless enchantment.
Oh shit, I hate this.
I hate that.
Alright, here we go.
Alright,
here we go.
Okay, let's see what's down.
I don't know how to do this.
Guys!
Guys, I'm calling in my coach!
Thomas Edison!
How does he do it?
Coach!
Coach, I'm struggling!
How do you do that, coach?
It's okay, the coach will save me.
Coach!
Okay, he did that.
Okay, coach is there.
Coach!
Coach Edison!
Thank you, coach Edison, with your power!
I shall be able to climb now.
No, oh, oh, oh, coach!
Coach!
Thank you, coach!
AHHHHH COACH!
Coach, I'm falling!
Is this supposed to happen?
Okay, all right, I figured out though.
I figured out how to get through that.
Coach said that was supposed to happen because I didn't do it.
I didn't do it good enough.
He said that coach Edison told me that because I didn't do the technique properly enough that I have to restart from down there.
Thank you!
Don't worry, coach.
I'll perfect this technique!
Yes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Pulling up the Ouija board every time.
Every time I have to contact their Oshii.
You don't understand!
Hehehehe.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
I need to climb up the rock.
HWAAA!
Oh, God.
Here we go.
Ah.
Eh!
COACH!
I SWEAR, COACH!
LET ME HAVE ANOTHER CHANCE!
I GOT THIS, COACH!
Hehehehe.
COACH!
Please don't make me restart!
Okay.
All right.
We gotta get up from here.
HWAAA!
There we go!
I figured it.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
It's fine.
We're fine.
Okay, we need two hands on this rock.
And then...
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
And then...
Reset.
No!
Woo!
Okay.
It's fine.
We can drop here.
It's our sanctuary.
Here we go.
Try it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just got here.
Thank you for joining at the beginning for me.
This isn't the beginning!
This is the sanctuary!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Here we go.
This is fine.
Okay.
We're good.
Oh!
We made it though.
We made it here.
This is fine.
Come on!
Just grasp it!
The Doki Grasp!
Okay.
Maybe the Doki Grasp back here.
Oh.
Let's see.
Okay.
All right.
Come on.
No!
Come on!
Please!
I just want to see the city!
I want to know what the city looks like!
I've only heard stories from Maoshi!
Please!
I remember when I first saw Maoshi.
Mr. Thomas Edison.
He promised me a tale.
He promised me a golden city.
If I reach the top!
Please!
Okay.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please.
Just...
Please let me grab it!
Why can't I grab water?
Why are you a liquid?
Are you stupid?
Okay.
All right.
I'm good.
I just need to grab this rock.
Please.
Just let me...
I can't even grab rocks anymore.
I can't even...
Okay.
Here we go.
Just like that.
Let me grab rocks.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
Let's grab things.
Tesla paid for all that!
You're getting shilled by the Tesla Corps!
Nice try Tesla propagandist!
You can't fool me!
Edison already told me to be careful with people like you!
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
I can not grab that rocket!
Don't be a sheep!
Open your eyes!
Oh thank god!
It just hit my head on the rock!
It's okay.
I'm still here!
Get off Twitter and read a book!
Tesla shill!
Read the history book!
No one talks about Tesla there!
They say history books are written by winners!
That means it's true!
That means Thomas Edison won!
So it's true!
Here we go.
Edison losing to Edward.
That's so true!
That's right!
That means Tesla's a loser!
If he's not in that history books!
Alright, let's go.
I didn't expect myself to start my day ranting about this.
Edison invents itself!
Exactly!
There it is!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
That's...here we go.
Make a bullet!
Edison versus Tesla!
I don't need a make a bullet!
Pick a paw!
I know who's a real winner!
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
You know now that I think about it...
Eventually somebody's gonna draw like...
Thishimen.
Is that how you pronounce it?
Um...Tesla and Edison.
Unless somebody's gonna draw like a manga about like...
Or something like... reading comics.
It's like, we just reincarnated Tesla and Edison in like modern world.
And then people are gonna ship this too.
I swear if it hasn't been done already, I know it's going to happen.
Manga has... Manga anime has no bounds.
It will always happen eventually.
It already exists.
I know.
Yeah, it came then Tesla and Edison.
I can feel it.
Edison is the jock and then...
And Tesla is the art kid.
Worlds collide.
Here you go.
If it hasn't happened yet, it's...
You guys know it.
Don't stop it.
You can't stop it.
Okay.
Here you go.
Please, let me grasp the rock.
Oh god.
And then... Okay, here you go.
And then like Edison and Tesla got assigned on a science project together.
And then Tesla's like...
Thought that like Edison and him were getting closer.
But then like he felt betrayed because Thomas Edison took all the credit for his work.
And he never talked to him again after the science project.
And then, he was heartbroken.
Stop.
Oh my god, the sanctuary.
Stop letting her cook.
Alright, here you go.
Alright, here we go.
I can't believe Duggazot cancelled over 200 year old corporate espionage.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, general.
Never cook again.
It exists.
I don't even need a cook.
I'm pretty sure it exists somewhere.
I'm pretty sure.
You can't stop it.
Alright, here we go.
There you go.
Nice.
We got the bush.
It's the rock.
I can never do the rock anymore!
I can never do the rock!
Okay.
Please!
Please for Edison!
Please.
Please, I just...
My coach is watching me.
He's filming this!
Please!
I don't want to be kicked out of the Edison Club!
I worked so hard!
There you go.
Oh, thank god.
No!
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Edison, you telegram.
Who's this?
Tesla fiercely typing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, sanctuary!
Sanctuary!
Because of the Hamilton musical, I've ironically seen people ship the historical figures of those guys they're based off.
So Tesla X Edison is definitely a thing that probably exists.
Exactly!
Anything is shippable!
You can avoid it!
Kitchen appliances can be shippable!
Are you thinking hard enough?
But please don't think hard enough, guys.
We don't need...
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
Doki, please stop cooking.
I'm not ready for Nicole Edison to ship this out.
Super chat, thank you, thank you.
It's too late.
I'm pretty sure it already exists.
I'm pretty sure.
We just need to make them anime boys.
To complete the trifecta.
We need to make them anime boys.
Or girls.
You know, cause that also works too.
If we can do it with countries!
We can do it with Tesla!
And Edison!
Not just once!
But three times!
Do you think it only happened in Italia?
No!
We've had personification of countries three fucking times!
And they are always getting shipped!
Stop cooking.
Three fucking times!
When will we stop?
Okay.
Anyway.
Here we go.
And one time they were just balls!
But yet people still shipped them!
They were just balls!
When will we learn?
We will never learn.
You're so right though.
What the hell is she yapping about?
No!
I got kicked out of my seat!
I talk too much!
No!
Tesla!
This is your fault!
America's only shit!
Your ship is to oil!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I got kicked out for talking too much!
For talking too much about shipping!
No!
The sanctuary!
I don't even remember I did this!
Okay.
Here we go.
The dokey grass!
No!
Oh my god.
It's not muscle memory anymore.
It's been too long since I've grasped here.
Okay.
We just gotta...
We just gotta do this.
The dokey swing.
Okay.
Please!
No!
Ninja!
Don't say that!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm sorry to tell you this dokey.
The game knows Tesla was right.
And will never let you see...
Please!
You will never change a Tesla empty!
You will never change my mind!
Edison forever!
Okay.
No!
Fuck!
Okay.
It's fine.
That doesn't count as a fall.
I grasped the mountain in time.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
We're gonna go up.
Woshi Edison for life!
Edison for life!
Mahoshi!
He can do no wrong!
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Grasp!
Okay.
Grasp.
I don't remember how to do the swing.
The dokey swing eludes me.
I spin.
My muscle memory is gone.
Okay.
Please don't!
Darkblade!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
As a child, Edison saved me from a burning building which was caused by Tesla's blatant and fork copy of Edison's work.
I am only alive due to Edison.
Thank you, Oshi Edison!
I am 100%...
See!
Look at that!
We have testimonies from fellow Edison fans!
Alright.
We as part of the Edison fandom We're called the Edison fans.
We're the...
We're...
What's our fan name, guys?
What is the Thomas Edison fan name, guys?
What are we?
The Edison's...
The Eddieheads...
As a fellow Eddiehead!
Uh...
The...
The Eddie's!
Oh!
I like that!
We're the Eddie's!
Guys, as a fellow Eddie's...
We will not let you tarnish our Oshi's name like this!
Fucking...
Stupid Tesla... The Tesla sons?
I don't know.
I don't care enough about the Tesla fandom to know what your fan name is!
Oh, please!
I can't swim anymore!
I saw Edison start the fire and take care of it.
No!
You did not!
That's a Tesla!
Yeah, that's my Oshi...
I like that the light bulb is my Oshi sign.
Yeah, that's what the fucking...
The fucking testicles say.
Yeah, that's right.
I call you testicles!
That's right!
What are you gonna do about it, huh?
You don't have cool names like us, the Eddie's.
That's fucking right.
Try to steal our Oshi mark too?
We all know Edison invented the light bulb.
Get your own Oshi mark.
Alright, here you go.
Alright, no please!
I just wanna get to the sanctuary.
Oh, there you go.
We got it.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
What is going on with you?
Why are you freaking out on me?
Bro, Eddie's forever.
Eddie's forever!
My true fandom.
Okay.
Here you go.
I need to remember how to fucking do the swing.
The swing is so hard, guys.
It's so difficult, guys.
Oh!
Oh, I did it!
No!
What?!
Yeah, Tesla.
More like Tess lame.
Oh!
Thank you for the super chat, man.
Thank you, thank you.
Jesus, please.
I just wanna go back.
Let me go back to the sanctuary.
Please.
Let me go back.
This game.
Please.
I have enough of FOMO.
I got the FOMO.
Ugh.
I already have enough.
I don't wanna miss.
I'm done missing out.
I'm okay with missing out now.
Okay, nice.
Okay, here you go.
Alright.
Okay.
Grab.
They don't know about my light pop Eddie's try.
Thank you for the super chat, guys.
Thank you.
No!
Why did you f- Neapolitan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We Eddies will not bow down to the Tessies.
Exactly.
That's right.
We don't even know what your fan names are.
We just call you Tessicles to make fun of you.
Alright, here you go.
Let's go.
No!
Come on!
Just let me back in.
I just wanna go back to the sanctuary.
Alright, here you go.
Ugh.
No, no.
Come on.
Come on!
Grasp!
Okay, maybe I go a bit higher.
Okay, here you go.
Nice.
No!
Not nice!
Not nice.
Like I said, I can't be as innocent as that.
Thank you for the super chat, Ninja.
Thank you.
You're just brainwashed.
Don't be a sheep.
Alright, here you go.
Okay.
Breezy.
Have you tried not falling?
I hear it's helpful.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, shit!
You're right.
Sorry, guys.
Sorry, I forgot.
I had my fall.
I had my fall button on.
I just turned it off, guys.
So you watch this.
Woo!
Fuck!
No!
Why do you fall like this?
Why?
Why do you fall like that?
Bro!
I just wanted to go to the city.
Okay, here you go.
Here you go.
It's okay.
I fall on purpose to perfect my technique, guys.
Like, I have to perfect my technique here in the beginning instead of like further down the line.
You know, guys?
Like, if I perfect it here, then I won't like fuck it up next time.
You know?
You gotta perfect it in the beginning.
So like, you can use it later on.
At the later stages.
There you go.
See?
Look at that.
Like the Doki grasp.
I perfected it here in the beginning, and because of that, like, I don't have to worry about fucking it up at the later stages.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Please.
Just let me experience.
Why?
Why did I hit my head in the sanctuary?
Why won't a shark just put me under my misery and just eat me?
Please.
Okay.
We're fine.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
Boop.
Up we go.
Imperial, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Grasp.
No.
It has to be like perfectly here.
Grasp!
Okay.
Got that down.
I got the grasp down.
Okay.
Yes!
Which arm is this?
Okay, it's this arm.
Okay.
Oh!
I hate this.
Please.
Oh!
Oh, please.
Please.
Please!
Ah!
I hate this so much.
Oh, God.
Oh!
The alien's grasp!
Okay.
Alright.
We made it.
Oh, I hate that sound though.
I hate that sound so much.
Okay.
WWED.
What will Edison do?
Always practice WWED.
Ah!
No!
I can't believe it.
We were there.
We were right there, chat.
It was actually right there.
No!
Why must you test me like this?
I've been in Advent any since you've debuted.
any since you've debuted.
No!
Okay.
Nice.
We got it.
This is Tesla's fault.
I can feel it.
Spreading his fucking propaganda.
You'll never convert me!
I'll never be a goddamn testicle!
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay.
Alright.
Crap.
Here.
Ugh!
UGH!
AHH!
No, no, no, no, no!
Here we go.
No!
I don't understand!
Everything else is so easy!
Yes.
Take me to the... I don't care.
I'm gonna settle.
I just wanna go to the sanctuary.
I'm settling.
I don't care anymore.
Just take me to the sanctuary.
I don't care.
WHAAAA!
Please.
I'm gonna settle!
Gwen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
When you wanna climb up but a game detects an Edison, support testicles.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No!
We're not gonna settle!
I can't!
I don't think we're making it to the city!
Okay.
Up!
There we go.
Alright.
At least I trademarked the Doki Grasp there.
Doki Grasp technique.
You're welcome.
Okay.
No!
Fuck!
God damn it!
This momentum!
I hate it!
I'm pretty sure I'm not even doing it correctly.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure that's not even the correct way to fucking do the swing.
God damn it!
Please.
That's like the hardest part.
The 360 swing.
Why is Edison not doing a 360 swing?
How does he do it?
Okay.
We need to realign ourselves here.
We need to realign ourselves to be at this edge.
And then...
Please.
Please just grasp this.
Oh god.
Okay.
We grasp that.
And then...
And then we go from here.
This part.
I hate this part so much.
Okay.
God damn it!
Let me go past this area!
We were so close!
See?
That's the worst part!
We were like right there!
We were literally right there!
Oh my god.
We were right there!
It was so close!
I literally saw the sanctuary!
The sanctuary!
We were right there!
Why did I have to hit my head?
Okay.
Alright.
There you go.
This is it.
I'm gonna try this swing.
I'm gonna try this.
Yes!
Oh!
I did it!
Perfected a new technique that's less...
That's less fucked up!
Guys!
I perfected a new technique guys!
No.
No!
I...
Please!
Just get me out of here!
I don't wanna be here anymore!
I just wanna be at the sanctuary!
Please!
Okay.
I don't understand!
Just... grasping!
Alright.
Like this.
This part we got down.
Hands down the easiest part.
Okay.
This part is the easiest part for us.
But...
For some reason...
There we go.
We can't do the other part!
No!
I wasn't... I didn't grab on the edge enough!
I've been playing for so long that my background music stopped!
My background music was like, are you sure?
Are you sure?
Please!
You're like, are you sure you wanna keep going, Doki?
This is getting embarrassing now.
I wanna settle.
That's all I want.
Just let me get there.
Let me get to that one area.
That's all.
Like, I don't want much.
Just let me be in my sanctuary.
Please.
If I make it to the first checkpoint.
That's all I want.
No!
I don't care about the city anymore!
It's not worth it!
Okay.
The city is not worth it.
I realize the city was a lie.
It was a lie all along.
Please.
No.
No no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no No, no, no, no...
Okay.
Please.
You gotta focus.
You gotta focus, Doki.
Just focus.
Just keep focusing.
Goodbye.
Oh god.
Okay.
Just keep focusing.
Just grab onto the top!
Oh god.
Just keep focusing.
The promised land.
The promised land is right there.
Don't fuck up.
Don't fuck up!
YES!
WE DID IT!
Okay, we can keep going.
No!
I'm settling.
I'm gonna settle.
I'm calling it.
This is my new home now.
I'm done with FOMO.
I beat the game.
Time!
FOMO is no more.
I've made it.
No more FOMO for me.
We did it!
Oh my god.
Thank you everybody for watching.
I'm done.
I'm sorry this is a short stream.
But I don't wanna risk losing my life.
I'm gonna lose my sanctuary.
I don't wanna risk it.
Okay guys.
Whenever we hit 800,000 subscribers.
Wait, where are we at?
Alright, 700,000 subscribers.
When we hit 700,000 subscribers, I will finish the game.
I will finish the game.
700K subscribers.
And I will finish the game.
But for now, this Eddy has to...
He's gonna peace out.
Alright guys.
I think we have a lot of super chats coming in.
So I'm gonna call it here everybody.
But like, thank you all for calling.
I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
Everyone.
It was very chaotic.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.